As before, we're just going to substitute four in for x in the original
function. So we're going to end up with 4 squared with is just equal to 16. So
our input of four spits out an output of 16. And once again this creates a point
for us that we can plot a 4 comma 16. This lies on the graph of f of x equals x
squared. Which incidentally is a problem you know very well. So the way that the
graphs of these functions look hasn't changed at all. From when we used to write
them with y's instead of f of x. So the graph of y equals x squared is exactly
the same as the graph of f of x equals x squared. Writing with this notation
just underscores the fact that this is a function. This has that special
property of having only one y value for every x value that we can plug in. And
it also shows that the vertical values on this graph are dependent, upon the
horizontal values.